several international institutions have
settled in the former government quarter
of the ex West German capital among them
is the United Nations campus in Germany
right next door develop reduces its
programs in many languages for broadcast
the world over also on the banks of the
Rhine are the headquarters of Deutsche
Post designed by star architect Helmut
yawn from 1949 to 1990 while Germany was
divided Balan served as the capital of
West Germany the parliamentary chambers
are now a historic site and a venue for
international conventions politics
occasionally has a place here too that
the l'homme Schmidt is the German
president's second official residence
the Chancellor's bungalow is open to the
public it's a prime example of 1960s
design of the leaders who lived within
its minimalist walls only Helmut Schmidt
and his wife Loki are said to have felt
truly at home the old town hall and
marked plots of the city's historic
center for nearly 200 years the
prince-electors of cologne resided in
Bonn and left their mark on the old town
in 1818 the university was established
in the former electoral palace the
pleasure garden became its campus bones
museums offer an abundance of art
culture and history
[Music]
the house deshita collects objects that
became part of Westermann life after
1945 among them are the limousine of
West Germany's first Chancellor Konrad
Adenauer and the parliamentarians first
benches in shares once sat on by home at
: Mikhail Gorbachev as they discussed
Germany's reunification in 1990